I've heard of Loire dumps but this is
getting ridiculous
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that Believe It or Not is able
to produce more than five episodes per
year suck on that traditional
entertainment and in case you overlooked
the title thumbnail opening gag in title
screen we're back to continue talking
about Rick and Morty because you know
what I like it you guys clearly like it
and we only get five of these this year
so might as well make them count
season four is second episode the old
man and the seat was everything we love
about this show a perfect blend of
cerebral existentialism and poop jokes
lore drops and other droppings and while
we've already seen a range of emotions
from Rick Sanchez from sad Rick - angry
Rick - bored Rick - pickle Rick this
episode managed to show us a new side of
his personality as well as allude to
details from his past which remains more
elusive than a jheri an immense amita
it's worth talking about this episode in
particular because the glimpses we get
into Rick's psyche are likely to set the
pace for what we can expect from this
character throughout the rest of the
season while also helping to clear up a
lot of misconceptions I think people
have about Rick as a character so to
recap in the episode Rick announces that
he's gonna be taking a solo adventure
I've got a quick solo adventure to go on
and this one will not be directed by Ron
Howard summer reveals that he's actually
going to poop and that Rick is believe
it or not a shy pooper who flies all the
way to an idyllic isolated planet to
poop on the porcelain throne of his
dreams he finds though that someone else
has been visiting his Oval Office and he
sets out to kill them in case you missed
this one Rick trying to keep anyone else
from pooping on his toilet as a metaphor
for him trying to keep other people away
from his personal life keeping them at
arm's distance from anything that feels
intimate obvious metaphor was pretty
obvious but you know wanted to make sure
that we were all starting with the same
baseline after a bit of detective work
Rick discovers the identity of the
trespassing pooper an alien office
worker named Tony Rick's plan to kill
Tony though changes once Rick finds out
that Tony's wife is dead can I look at a
photo of my wife while you'll kill me
she's dead and I don't mind joining her
rick experiences a sudden and
characteristic change of heart and
leaves a fart bomb instead of outright
killing Tony why well we're gonna come
back to that
in the meantime Tony can't seem to let
the toilet go and invades Rick's private
domain yet again here Tony shows that
he's no dumb-dumb by explaining to Rick
why he's the shy pooper you know a chai
popping is Rick it's a pointless bid for
control you want to take the one part of
life that you truly think is yours and
you want to protect it from a universe
that takes whatever it wants it took my
wife it clearly took something from you
again explaining the reason Rick likes
to be the only person on the entire
planet while he's pooping is because
it's the only way he feels safe and in
control Rick knows that there are
infinite planets and universes and
realities and that everything happening
in them is chaotic and random so having
his special poopy time is the only thing
Rick can really control in the end with
his past and future are so out of his
hands it's a frustration that he's
talked about in past episodes
specifically the season 3 episode ABCs
of Beth the universe is basically an
animal you know smart people get a
chance to climb on top take reality for
a ride but it'll never stop trying to
throw you and eventually it will but
here it's made even more clear so the
episode escalates when Rick places Tony
in a version of the matrix designed to
create a heaven like experience the
chemical is global fan it connects to
whatever you want section of your brain
to the whatever you have section in
other words Rick gives Tony everything
that he could have ever wanted and ideal
existence and Tony's mind rejects it
this is because Tony can't accept his
own happiness
he's scared off from it forcing him to
be miserable sound familiar
should because that's exactly how Rick
operates Rick is a man who can make a
perfectly realized islet film simulation
of heaven but the one thing he can't
make the one problem he can't figure out
is how to be happy it's ironic he's the
smartest man in the universe who can
become a pickle or travel to infinite
realities but he's miserable and there's
no way that he can science his way out
of it it's something that he actually
addresses to Beth during season 3 am i
evil
worse you're smart when you know nothing
matters the universe is yours and I've
never met a universe that was into it
and so finally Rick has found Tony
someone who's as unable to accept
happiness as Rick is unlike all the
others in the simulation pods Tony
rejects a perfect life which
simultaneously makes Rick feel more
connected to Tony but at the same time
pisses him off so
a final bid to push Tony out of his life
Rick tries to pull off an epic prank by
feeding Tony a laxative only to discover
that Tony's died while out living life
to the fullest
Rick offers his condolences as a
generous gift to his family while also
denying that the two were ever friends
hey Tony's dad this is 8 billion in your
local currency and this is a kid who's a
clone a new son it's not my friend as
Rick mourns the loss of his not friend
Tony he sits down on the toilet
triggering the trap that he had set
another epic prank that involves a
thousand Holograms of Rick pointing and
laughing at him Rick sits on his
porcelain throne the king of loneliness
[Music]
the show in this episode isn't exactly
subtle with its metaphors and messaging
but there's still a lot to tease out
fundamentally this episode is all about
the ways Rick keeps the people around
him at a distance the way Rick behaves
now is fundamentally influenced by his
past just like Tony's life is influenced
by the loss of his wife
when Tony mentions that loss it sparks a
complete change of heart and Rick
indicating that Tony's story has struck
a chord Rick has also experienced a
great loss that's what's caused them
both to be shied poopers now up to this
point the truth about Rick Sanchez's
past has been the show's greatest
mystery why was Rick out of Beth's life
for so many years where is Beth's mother
and what did Rick do to her we know
based on the existence of Beth that she
must have existed at some point rights
well anyone who knows this show well
will immediately jump back to one of its
most iconic episodes season 3 episode 1
rick shank redemption which was all
about show knees and memory hopping in
rick shank redemption rick dives into
memories to show us and a grumps almight
investigator the day that a younger Rick
Sanchez had two tragically watch his
partner Diane die
except as Rick leader tells us this
isn't a real memory it was just a
totally fabricated origin story now well
the memory itself may definitely be
fabricated there is some real-world
science that allows us to theorize about
whether it's actually that far from the
truth it turns out that humans are
really bad at coming up with original
ideas in fact many neuroscientists
believe that new ideas don't even exist
instead our brains are constantly remix
we hear feel smell or taste researchers
at the University of Haifa found that
when forming an original idea the brain
utilizes an associative region which is
what we think of as our creative
thinking what's interesting though is
that this associative part of the brain
still fundamentally involves recombining
ideas that are already stored inside the
brain what we think of as coming up with
new ideas is actually just re mixing old
ideas in new ways this was actually
confirmed by researchers at the
Institute of psychology of the
University of Graz Austria who confirmed
that coming up with a new idea and
recalling an old memory actually show
similar activation patterns in the brain
that's not to say that we can't remix
ideas to come up with stuff that's
incredibly innovative just means that in
Rick shank redemption there's a pretty
good likelihood that Rick's fabricated
memories are actually based on some very
real-world experiences so let's look at
that fabricated memory again Diane and
Beth both died by Rick's own hand
another Rick visits him from a different
timeline offering him the opportunity to
be a God pass excuse me who do you think
you are a different kind of Rick I guess
well see how long that lasts
Rick rejects the offer a bomb drops into
the garage sent via portal to kill off
his family we can assume that this was
sent by the other Rick's to set our Rick
on the quote-unquote right path now we
know that this isn't what really
happened to Diane as Beth says in the
episode Rick potion number nine do you
think grandpa Rick had something to do
with this
it's not fair to assume that summer give
me a break he is a selfish irresponsible
butt and he left my mother her real man
stands by his Worman so while the faked
memory may not be how it actually went
down in a symbolic sense it shows us
that Rick blames himself and his war
for pushing Diane and Beth out of his
life well it's exciting to imagine this
being caused by sci-fi high jinks the
reality here is probably more mundane
and less all the more infuriating for
Rick Dan died in his life because a Rick
strive to be the best scientific mind
pushed her away in the process he lost
the relationship with the one and only
thing that could grant him true
happiness his family he realized long
ago that the greatest thing he'd ever
create there are a lot of other analysis
channels and articles that have tried to
diagnose Rick with some sort of mental
disorder often settling on diagnoses
like narcissistic personality disorder
or antisocial personality disorder but
this episode shows that we can flush
both of these diagnoses right out
although Rick sees himself as the
smartest person in the galaxy and seems
to lack empathy he doesn't actually have
narcissistic personality disorder it's
more that he's suppressed his empathy
probably because he himself views it as
toxic as we saw on the episode rest and
relaxation as much as Rick might hate it
he does care for his grandson so much so
that even the seemingly hateful toxic
version of Rick is willing to abandon
his destructive quest in order to save
Morty are you okay
likewise Rick doesn't suffer from
antisocial personality disorder or
psychopathy either which is
characterized by a complete lack of
remorse for all your actions now while
it might not seem like it at first
glance Rick constantly experiences
remorse throughout the series for
starters his alcoholism alone is clearly
self-medicating to cope with feelings of
existential loss and unhappiness in the
old man in the seat he attempts to make
right by Tony by extending a
well-meaning offer of kindness to his
father Rick is even willing to put
Morty's life above his own as we see in
a wrinkle in time when Morty loses his
time stabilizing caller and Rick takes
off his own collar to give Morty a way
out of a certain death situation okay
with this
be good Morty be better than me
are hardly the actions of a narcissist
or psychopath so then how do we explain
Rick's clear and intentional acts of
cruelty towards Tony if Rick is so
desperate for a friend and isn't
actually a psychopath well it's actually
really easy much more mundane and
tremendously sad anger hostility lashing
out at those who are closest to us
they're all common but under talked
about symptoms of depression which comes
from our own feelings of being
inadequate those of us who are depressed
often hurt the people that are closest
to them because deep down they believe
that they're undeserving of love or
happiness their hostility pushes other
people away thereby confirming their own
feelings of inadequacy there have also
been a number of reports on the fact
that we're most aggressive towards the
people we love because those are the
ones who are most in a position to hurt
us
taking these ideas and applying them to
Rick it becomes clear why he reserves
the cruelest of his insults for his
grandkids when it comes to Jerry Rick
barely expresses more than minor
annoyance when it comes to people Rick
actually hates he's content to kill him
without insult even letting him have the
last laugh dr. Ben Zev from the
University of Haifa notes in his book
the subtlety of emotions that another
reason for hurting those closest to us
is a wish for more dependency and
attention could Rick's cruelty actually
be a bid for attention
well his catchphrase is what I love a
job done which we're told means I am in
great pain please help me so yeah I'd
say we're barking up the right tree
so when Rick arranges elaborately cruel
pranks to play on Tony what he's really
saying is pay attention to me because
secretly that's what I really want
Tony understands that cry for help and
is thus his friend and interestingly
enough there's one final twist here
because when you apply this same logic
to the members of his family we come up
with Rick's favorite co-star being
summer and if you look at what actually
happens in the episodes it makes total
sense it's summer who joins Rick in
getting all right it up and punching the
devil it's summer who goes native in
their Mad Max adventures and Rick man
seing the stone to the point where Rick
specifically complements her on her
creative use of his booze
for the win it's summer who recognizes
tiny Rick's downward spiral in big
trouble and little Sanchez thanks kids
you figured it out
well summer did it's the reason she's
the failsafe when it comes to Morty's
mine blowers and yet we get some of the
worst insults reserved for her
get out of here summer you ruined the
season four premiere Rick actively
excludes her permissions despite the
fact that she's undoubtedly smarter and
more capable than Morty she's even saved
Rick's life on multiple occasions and
like Tony he can't kill her he can't get
rid of her in his life so he actively
undervalues and insults her tries to
push her away and keep her at arm's
distance but summer sticks around she
lets it roll off her she recognizes what
her grandpa is really doing and she's
able to dish back summer's been playing
a more active role in a lot of the
episodes that have been coming out over
the last season and a half
so maybe with Rick forced to confront
more of his emotional hang-ups summer
will ultimately end up being the key to
unlock it all only time will tell if
that's just a theory a film theory
[Music]